every great movement starts with one
person
someone who isn't afraid to go against
the odds
someone who isn't bound by limitations
[Music]
someone who sees an opportunity
someone who wants to challenge the
status quo
what we forget about the price they had
to pay to get there
[Music]
gone from afraid to doing the impossible
call from overdrawn bank accounts to
having financial freedom
[Music]
come from employee to CEO
come from barely making it to living a
fantasy
[Music]
so to the person who wasn't the smartest
person in school
[Music]
to the person who lost everything wants
a chance to make a comeback
[Music]
- the person that feels confined by
rules
[Music]
did a person who feels content but feels
they have more to offer in life
[Music]
that a person who simply doesn't believe
that this is it remember every great
movement started with one person
[Music]
a person with clear goals a person that
was willing to put into work a person
that was stubborn enough to not quit
a person that wasn't afraid of being the
underdog a person that is willing to
push the envelope what if that one
person is you
[Music]